hello and welcome to the new old review
source for everything anime and manga
and today we are here to engulf
ourselves in the sheer desolation
that is the spade kingdom arc of black
clover or at least i think that's what
it might be called i don't know on the
wiki it just says arc 11 which is such a
lame name for such a powerhouse
experience and sadly no i did not reach
the end of it in one sitting i got to
around chapter 260 which felt like a
pretty depressing yet natural place to
stop with far too much to discuss as it
is and for some reference that's about
the point where the army got abducted
and asked to go left
in despair poor poor astor but at least
he has a cool sword now that
is a definite plus in any case there was
too much to discuss which was quite
problematic really just like you not
being subscribed to the new world review
problematic because how else will i know
that you would like regular
black cover content uploaded straight
into your youtube feed
hmm you gotta think about these things
but alright the premise of this arc
seems almost wildly simple
aster and select friends of asta have
been training in the heart kingdom for
the past six months during that time
asda has gotten big
very big not taller i think just wider
but still
very wide then all of a sudden the spade
kingdom invades and we spend
i think a good 30 chapters locked in
non-stop devil fraught death-defying
combat
so it's somewhat like the beginning of
the reincarnation arc in a way
just with significantly less build and
lead in time with the whole royal knight
fiasco thing
and that was definitely noticeable
tarbital wasted no time at all throwing
us straight into the deep end here and
bam before i knew it we were locked in
battle with all three of the dark
triad yeah the evil spade dudes and the
one dudette and you can more or less
divide this 30 chapter part of the arc
into a simple discussion about each one
of them the first member we were
properly introduced to being zeno who
was entrusted with the mission of
assaulting the golden dawn headquarters
in an effort to obtain william vengeance
and his delightful world tree magic and
the first thing of note is that i like
william's new lifestyle choice not to
wear his mask around all the time or
even at all that's a pretty big step
considering that he is still
cursed and everything but it is also
very thematically appropriate given that
he has nothing left to hide after that
whole
elf event so as a result there is no
internal need for a mask
and as such no need for an external mask
fantastic
as for zeno himself i have no strong
impression of him at this stage out of
the three dark triad members he's the
most stoic and serious he's your
classical cool and collected bad guy
he has a great design though i do like
the positioning of the cross on his face
i also do like his bone magic that looks
very cool but
otherwise he's just a little bit too
plain to me at this point although part
of the problem with that may be that
zeno's part of the story here is
completely overshadowed by yuno who
as it turns out is not only a member of
royalty as i've been assuming but he is
actually the last prince of the spade
kingdom
certainly wasn't quite expecting him to
be that important but it's a nice
confirmation of my working thoughts
regarding him everything just
makes perfect sense with this revealed
and by everything i mostly mean just his
natural talent
of course it does throw an interesting
question into the mix as well as the
royalty of the spade kingdom will this
impede euno's quest to become there was
a king like will he eventually take up
that sort of role but on behalf of the
spade kingdom leaving the door wide open
for astor to become the wizard king of
the clover kingdom and thus engineering
a situation
where both of them get to do that thing
that they wanted to do or maybe because
the diamond and heart kingdoms are in
ruins anyway we'll end this arc with all
four nations coming together under one
ruler
and keep that rivalry in tow i don't
know thoughts thoughts to be had by me
right now however this arc has finally
given me what i've wanted to see for
quite some time which is you know
having his arse handed to him it was
quite something to finally see yuno hit
that all-important wall that astor seems
to charge into with every minor step he
takes because yuno has never really been
put in a spot where he's had to do that
cool thing of surpassing his limits his
limits were just always naturally
outrageous but now
now he's going to have to do that exact
thing and what results is bound to be
pretty amazing although another
highlight here was the very surprising
klaus
it's now incredibly clear that he has
adopted astor's mentality and over the
past six months perhaps even more klaus
has seen himself rigorously train and
surpass his own limits as a magic knight
sadly though it did not help a whole lot
if at all in the end but i still
appreciated that character growth i also
thought that maybe
just maybe tarbata might have finally
killed someone worthwhile that's someone
being class
seeing klaus's body hanging on the verge
of death sent a sudden jolt down my
spine before i realized that this is
black clover and everyone was healed i
mean to be fair no not everyone was
healed there were heavy casualties
within the golden dawn they just
well they happened to be the characters
that we didn't know and or care about
all the ones that we did know and care
about survived so
that's convenient still we are getting
one closer to a meaningful death so i
will take it elsewhere the heart kingdom
is being invaded by our second dark
triad member veronica who i would say is
probably my favorite because she has by
far the most personality even if it is
really channeled into this
devilishly dominatrix lifestyle and who
knows perhaps that's what i like most
about her in any case she is also a lot
more meaningful at the moment because
her devil happens to be magikala the one
who cursed noelle's mother so already i
feel i have a much more vested interest
in seeing her defeat as opposed to the
other two so of course it's highly
appropriate that she became noelle's
opponent
sort of which speaking of that fight was
kind of amazing firstly i love that noel
got to show up for training on a couple
of different levels one of which would
be a new iteration of the valkyrie armor
designed specifically to allow noel to
fight within water
valkyriama mermaid edition and also noel
has this distinctly more
aster vibe going on about her now and
there was this particular moment where
she did a very astor thing which was his
trademark
suicide launch right at wanaka managing
to get in a pretty damn good strike as
well and apart from yami i really do
think that noel is one of my favorite
characters to see in combat in black
clover she has a ton of raw power a
variety of applications and now an
enduring never give up attitude clad her
in some magic warrior armor and we are
good to go
more of this plis and the heart kingdom
had a bunch of other fun fights as well
involving charmy luck and leopold i'm
not going to go into all of them in any
depth any depth at all i don't really
care enough but it was
intriguing to see the evolution of the
black clover magic system at play such
as invoking features like true magic and
arrays i always enjoy new features like
that and how they get casually
integrated into future fights like we
now have with mana zone and mana skin
and such
what i'm not quite enjoying is our new
scaling system this whole
stages thing within a couple of chapters
of being introduced it feels almost
completely meaningless because even the
fodder style disciple dudes in this arc
are automatically stage zeros and a
whole ton of our characters just sit in
the arcane stage anyway and it's just
like well why
even bother introducing the system if
everyone of importance and in fact even
those of very minimal importance like
the disciples are just always going to
be
at the top of that pyramid anyway
probably the only decent thing that
stages have going for them right now was
a brief
flashback with magna flagging him as a
stage five or whatever and is seemingly
motivating him to grow in return at some
point otherwise
i just got kind of sick of the stage
talk although nowhere near as much as
the percentage talk holy crap at some
points in this arc it felt like
old-school dragon ball z
all over again with villains claiming
that they're only using x percent of
their power and it's all just
unnecessary scaling and i feel like
they'd all be much more threatening
villains if we had no idea how close
they were to using their maximum devil
potential
which i suppose brings us to dante who
has probably the most exciting segment
getting to face off against asta and
yami before getting into that though i
do want to say that
asta has changed during these six months
and not just in terms of width either i
mean he has but also mentally he's
matured a hell of a lot which is very
apparent in his first scuffle with the
spade kingdom nobodies
during the section tabitha both drew and
wrote aston in a much more mature vein
and the way i would describe it is if
pre-time skip aster was a boy full of
baseless confidence then post-time
skipasta is a man whose confidence has a
very firmly rooted base he isn't all
talk anymore and i really like this new
version of him also he can fly on a
sword which is
that's cool and highly useful back to
dante though this is the most
interesting section because he unveils
our big plan
thing which involves a surprising
combination of yami and william
combination of arcane world tree and
dark magic required to open a magical
tree channel
known as klaiphoth or clifford i've
never really been sure which one it is
but it's a name that i'm quite familiar
with due to berserk where it gets used
for much the same sort of purpose a
bridge between worlds which is fun i do
like the idea of mixing and matching
magic like this
i mean we need an evil tree sure let's
grab the tree guy and the dark guy and
we'll smush them together
thus resulting in some sort of dark tree
i like it and the army does go on to
have a pretty spectacular battle against
dante once again doing the thing he does
and surpassing his limits right there on
the spot although on this one occasion
not even that was enough and he
implored astor for help the two of which
made a pretty fantastic team
especially right at the end were asked
to ran out of swords so yami tossed his
own to deliver the final blow it was so
damn cool and i did notice that after
the army got captured his sword was
still there so i do hope that astor
inherits it and becomes significantly
more of a badass than he already is
maybe even incorporate it into his
anti-magic shenanigans book
of course to win the fight against dante
astor also needed to have a conversation
with mr devil or i'm assuming
mr devil i don't know his or her name
yet although we get lots of other devil
names such as luciferio and zagreb the
latter of which was the name of the
devil that we had previously defeated
what we do know is that asda's devil is
seemingly very lowly ranked compared to
zagred magikala luciferio and
i don't remember the other one's name if
we did find that out
still as it turns out aston's devil is
basically the devil equivalent of astor
low ranking peasant scum so they should
make quite a great team really meanwhile
dante is defeated but not before
presenting his opposing philosophy of
only being most human when unleashing
your darkest emotions so he is being set
up disastrous polar opposite and i have
to say i was surprised that he was
actually beaten at the end especially at
a mighty 80 percent of devil power
but then again if this arc is going to
be anything like tabata's previous
entries then i imagine that ass bay trio
aren't actually going to end up as the
major climactic antagonist and there
will be someone or something or some
things plural
even bigots take down as far as the arc
goes so far though tarbeta has moved in
pretty fast and furiously i really
wasn't prepared for the speed in which
we just casually mentioned stuff like oh
yeah the diamond kingdom's been like
totally conquered off-screen well almost
totally conquered and just yeah in
general the stakes went from zero to a
thousand just in an instant and
something else i also want to ask
margaritas about i'm just curious but a
black clover chapter's shorter at this
point
it might just be because they were
mostly action based but it feels like
going through chapters took much less
time than usual i noticed that most of
them were around 15 pages which is
definitely less than your standard 18
that gets published in weekly shown and
jump for other series and i'm not sure
if it's been like that the whole time
and i just didn't notice or if at this
point
tombato is cut down for some sort of
reason in any case this whole spade
kingdom business does hold a lot of
promise i very much enjoy that we're now
getting sea devil usage beyond aster and
any time that someone accesses that
devil power it results in simply
stunning artwork from tarpita he has a
really solid mastery of how to use
shades and just pure black to great
effect as well
as a fun general devil aesthetic to play
with but really this is going to be
another long one isn't it
30 chapters or so down and i feel like
we've only just finished the
introduction this whole section was one
big showcase of initial battles and a
widespread call to action and i don't
know exactly how much of the series is
left i think it's only about 20 chapters
or so at the time of this recording
before i need to make that switch to
weekly but regardless i very much do
look forward to finishing the black
clover journey
next week and what do you guys think
please do leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
black clover content then please do feel
free to check out some of my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for very maybe regular black clover
goodness delivered straight into your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review and i'll see you
next time